the hour being 10 o'clock I'll open the
public works and highways subcommittee
on lapse extensions and with with your
Indulgence I'll take one minute to
explain what the purpose of the
subcommittee is if you look in the back
of house bill 25 there's several pages
of what we call lapse extensions any
amount that's not listed there that was
appropriate on a prior budget would
lapse on June 30th of this year unless
it's extended and that could put an
agency in a position where they can't
pay a bill on a contract they've already
awarded conversely if there is
Appropriations that are lapsing we can
see if there is a usable amount of
funding remaining in that line and apply
it to some other project that we would
like to fund in this budget our first
agency is the Department of
administrative services and commissioner
arlinghaus is here in Karen montamaki
who's the director of plant and properly
management and having said what I want
to say uh
commissioner of the floor is yours um
thank you for having us um Karen's going
to talk for almost the entire time which
is great for me
um about uh our lapses and as you know
we have a ton of projects uh most of
which are still in process of
construction but I think she has a good
summary of where we are and then I'll I
can answer questions about the IT
project she can answer the ones about
all the other ones
great good morning
um so I'll start off by kind of going
over in general the entire list I won't
spend time on each individual
appropriation and feel free to you know
ask questions
um so the first big chunk of projects
are fiscal projects that were approved
in fiscal 21 and essentially all of
those are either ongoing or awaiting
um to be started and the reason is
there's just a huge lag right now with
acquiring equipment so delays on getting
equipment and also you know there's a
it's hard to get contracts so we we put
things out to bid and we're either
getting no bids or one bid and so some
things are going out multiple times so
essentially all of the fiscal 21
projects we're asking to be extended
um
then kind of moving on there's a few
projects where there's
you know 20 or less remaining and those
we've indicated that those should lapse
those are projects that were completed
there's one here with a dollar left
um so again I'm not going to spend a lot
of time on those and you're not you're
not going to see a whole lot of money
coming back on those either
um but then kind of moving moving
through the list one project that I
wanted to talk about a little bit was
from 2015
um it was an appropriation for a burger
uh burglar alarm system
um which there's a hundred and seventy
thousand dollars left in that project
um we are that was not one that we had
indicated to lapse earlier
um
but we're thinking that that we might
want to offer that one as a lapse
because it's a project that we're we're
not going to continue on with or go any
further with at this time
um
again there's a lot of projects uh
starting with the fiscal 17 projects
that are still in process they're kind
of awaiting final payments or getting
completed so we're asking for those to
be extended the next project from fiscal
17 and again I do need me to cite the
the number would that be helpful or
well the the one you mentioned about the
um
my list has the sorry I'm looking at the
um the law number is what I have on mine
so it's not matching up with what you
have on your list
um
from 17 there's a State Library roof
project that again has 58
165 dollars in it that is another one
that we had originally not indicated to
lapse but that's one that is complete
and we're we're able to lapse that fifty
I think that's why we have State Library
parapet and ceiling repair
so it looks like we're going to elapse
um
and then there were a few smaller lapses
that I had already indicated
um that we would be lapsing those and
I'll just point those out
um if we're keeping track of dollars
here so the next one would be from 2017
as well
okay and there's 3 700 left in that
project
and then there's a a thousand one
thousand twenty two dollars left in the
Bancroft building stabilization project
what would it be if I go through the
ones I think you're elapsing and you
tell me if you agree with them that
would be great starting with the oldest
one it's main building Bakery from 2009
yes with one dollar left okay and
then you said 51 the burglar alarm with
how much remaining
I have 170 450.
okay that sounds like a good chunk and
then the one above that uh state-owned
that one would not lapse
well
now is that 98 533 uh so that's 15 A1
state-owned facilities emergency repairs
is not in the list oh it's not in the
list you're right okay so that should
lapse that should lapse all right the
one above that is Erp scheduling and
20 uh that one would like it has 19 508
left
and then 17 C2 main building North End
Ada access
yes 3700 okay and then uh from 17 B10
and then the one you mentioned uh B9
State Library parapet and ceiling repair
yes we are adding that the one above
that is B5 Health and Human Services
yes that's there's no funds remaining in
that so that would last and then uh 17b1
doit new computer fire room uh new
computer room fire system
that is complete as well okay and then
uh from 19 uh
section 14 bankrupt building
stabilization
correct with one thousand twenty two
dollars and then
that one's also not on our list I think
that's a boiler project that came off
because it's completed and then 19d2
yes no funds remaining in that okay and
19 C5 paint and carpentry electrical
service and entrance yes and that has 17
218 dollars so that would lapse and then
19 B7 temporary boiler
this is this is history here temporary
boiler infrastructure removal yes
yeah 163 and then the Walker building
HVAC which is 19 B1 yes and that has no
okay those are the ones that I had that
are not mentioned in this budget
that were either appropriated or uh
yes and that matches up with my list
okay
and if you could send your list to uh Mr
Shea like we did last time so he can
cross check it with his and we can total
up the amount of funds that we have
so out of all of that we're going to
uh from from this year's House Bill 25
we're going to delete 46 and 51. correct
okay and so you have 50 minutes to say
whatever you would like to see
so I did a lot whenever Mr chairman
get a copy of this list because you're
working off of a list that is not
available to me and I can't I don't know
of the rest of my colleagues here have
access to the same list and respectfully
I feel like I'm Flying Blind with the
last five minutes of testimony between
yourself and uh administrative services
well uh I'm I'm not opposed to giving
you that I don't have extra copies with
me this is something that I made over
the weekend that I've never done before
actually
most of the time we rely on the agency
to know this
uh but this time I'm able to cross check
I'll I'll send this out
I'll send the whole committee the whole
subcommittee um if you want a list of uh
our list of projects based on what is
and isn't lapsing
so that you have that as well as opposed
to
the
okay
and representative
uh would it be possible to ask that if
that list of what Eve's working on gets
cross reference to the lapse extension
worksheet so by number so we could
quickly go down by the number to
understand which
item that it is
I think this is similar to ours because
they have the 21s and all the 19s
so I'll just briefly say that with the
projects other than the few dollars the
ones that had a few dollars in it it's
about 250 000 give or take
um and then commissioner arlinghaus do
you want to speak on any of the other IT
projects the the IT projects are are
mostly the institutional
um
uh the Erp advancement and that's money
that we're using for the cloud project
that recently there's a an additional 15
million in arpa funds for fiscal that is
on top of um both of those two
um those two requests as well
so the the IT projects are all being
used for the for the new Cloud
implementation
so we would appreciate it if they did
not lapse
the one of them from 2017 it only has
nineteen thousand dollars left in it so
if you really wanted that you could have
that
normally we will consider a repurpose on
anything 10th out with a balance of 10
000 or more I think is what we've done
in the past so okay now 19 here and 19
there tends to add up if you have enough
of them
We No it's it's uh frankly for the uh
I mean the proud the cloud project in
the end is going to cost between 22 and
24 million dollars so every 19 probably
I can explain the sheet if people want
to try to understand it and it um if
only because I didn't at first so
um if you look at the org code
description this is the this is how it's
sorted and you'll see
um l21 meaning it's from the lows of 21.
and then they're sorted within that
and obviously those are the ones that
Karen said on our lapsing after that it
reverts to
chronological order so the one project
from 09 with the dollar left in it that
we were happy to lapse the dollar
um is first and there's one left from 11
two left from 15. a handful from 17 and
then all of the 19s
did you want to talk about the Philbrook
yes we can talk brief
so I believe that came around as well
and everyone has a copy of the
informational item from last week's
capital budget overview meeting
um so really this came to us from Health
and Human Services and they had asked if
we could put in an item to
amend the agency
um who's in charge of the funding so it
was originally put in as a dis project
because when the capital budget was
submitted it was a building that we
owned or managed which was used for
office space and has since been
converted to a patient care facility
which Das is no longer involved in
maintaining and caring for that building
so we'd like to ask that the capital
appropriation
um which was from 2021 item seven yep be
reassigned to Health and Human Services
yeah
um just a couple other items I guess so
one thing
um
if this is the appropriate place to
bring it up is um we have money
appropriated for a roof project
um
for
Paisley annexed at the main building
it's a 2017 project
um
and we're no longer planning on
repairing or replacing that roof as that
piece of the main building is in such
disrepair that we're looking to
discontinue any use of that section but
we do have another area in Maine
building the North Pavilion that needs a
roof and so we were wondering if we
could possibly add language instead of
using it for the Paisley Annex portion
of main building to use it for the North
all right so
the suggestion is item 48 should be
repurposed from Peasley Wing roof
replacement to North Pavilion
correct and we'll take that back to the
full committee
chances are we would do them but
it's a little bit more drafting work so
but sure we want to use the money if
it's available happy to help with that
representative Newman
thank you on the roof replacement that
you're not doing on the Paisley building
does that roof need a replacement you're
just not going to do it now or it's not
critical
honestly if it was possible we would
probably take down that piece of the
main building it's in it's an older area
with very thick cinder block walls that
was kind of used as a detention cells in
the past and it's really not usable as
office space because of that and so it's
been used as storage but would require
major major steel reinforcement and in
order to reuse it for anything and it's
just Cost prohibitive to restore it for
what we would end up with so we're we're
it would be our choice to not put the
roof on if that at all yeah just
following up it would also be your
choice to take the building down
eventually yeah that would be what we'd
like to do
okay is it is it a hazard of any or an
attractive nuisance the way it is right
now
it's I would say no I mean but as you
probably know if if it continues to
remain in place over time it would
degrade further and then it might become
all right see no further questions let
me just recap this so item seven we want
to amend
uh item
the uh
46 we want to lapse so delete from House
Bill 25
same with 51 and 48 we want to repurpose
thank you
anything further anyone wants to say no
thanks for having us all right we're
always happy to have you your the
backbone of our construction Battalion
here uh we couldn't do it without the
people to find people in the in the
Bureau of Public Works
while we have time here I will go
through
uh the agencies that responded by mail
that we have information from
on line 54 agriculture markets and food
would like to keep that one
uh we heard from the community colleges
in their full committee presentation
they want to add
an extension for in 2021
section 14
for critical maintenance
they want to add from 2019
uh letter B NCC engineering technology
renovation agency
and their item from 2017 a critical
maintenance and safety they want to
lapse
directions is coming in
they are there and we have that in this
packet
uh
they they have from 74 down to 77
they are prepared to delete item 77
the renovation of the Hudson CTE Center
that project is complete and from 17 uh
they're going to lapse pre-engineering
technology
the department of energy would like to
they that's also in this packet
uh wants to extend the fuel assistance
program that's 100 Federal Environmental
services will be in fish and game uh
spoke on this in their
full committee presentation
the powder the item number
they would like to repurpose so they can
use it Statewide on any fish hatchery
and we have that request
and from 17 Hatchery infrastructure
improvements will lapse
item number after item number 131 we
would add from 2019 letter C cyber
security program enhancements
and from 17 the Statewide archiving
assessment would lapse chairman Jack
yeah could I just interrupt for a brief
moment just for ease of following along
there's a packet that everybody got that
has Department of Education on the top
of it it's in order
of the lapse extension worksheet so if
you as representative Jack gets to say
fish and game as he did you'll find an
email from the director Mason that tells
you what he would like to have happen so
just so you can follow along
people shuffling through papers and if
I'm going too quickly please stop me
because I have it all neatly organized
here
um from judicial branch
they would like to delete items 197 and
I'm sorry 137 and 138
from 2017 and 2015.
the e-court project presumably that's
because those funds are fully expended
from legislative branch
we want to delete item 139
uh which is state house complex building
maintenance
The Liquor Commission was in and covered
this during their full committee
presentation
lapse 2019 a from the credit card
project and then
from 2017
[Music]
um
item 14 they wanted to repurp their
their adding more money in this budget
and they have money from 17 that they
haven't spent so they wanted to combine
those into Life Safety roof replacement
and parking lot
so that would be a repurpose an
amendment of The
appropriation in the main part of the
bill
to include roof replacement or parking
lot so they can spend all of the money
on all of those things
military Affairs will be in later the
NCR will be in later
peas we're waiting to hear the uh
director of the of ports uh was out of
town and will get back to us today
these are money from the work that was
done on the Turning basin
Department of Revenue is it
Department of Revenue Administration
responded to us they would like to keep
item 177
Mr
yes
when you're going through these if
you're Mr Shea helped me with this one
here but if you're working off of this
sheet would you be so good as to give a
page number or the number well I I have
been giving the the line the item number
in section 12 there
okay got it yeah
all right
and police standards and training uh
would like us to add
their item from 2019 a for boiler
replacement they covered that when they
were here
safety covered theirs when they were
here in the full committee uh they want
to reap they the uh items from 21
section 12 2 and 3
for the hanger they would like to
repurpose those to add a renovation
component because they don't at this
time plan to reconstruct that there's
not enough money to do that
so they're planning to renovate it
instead
Transportation will be in I skipped
safety there's nothing and then um
the veterans home
they covered this in the fall committee
presentation
uh I guess they're going to lapse the
heat pump
and then in 223
they are prepared to delete that and
that has that has 1.293 million dollars
in that appropriation that's available
for us to use
so that covers what I have
for the agencies that responded by mail
so with that our next agency is in at
11. normally we have a more lengthy
presentation from administrative
services
uh but we're in recess until 11 when we
okay
the hour being 11 o'clock we will
reconvene the subcommittee with the
Department of Environmental Services
and we have Robert Scott the
commissioner and Sue Carlson the Chief
Financial Officer
and before we start I'd like to ask you
about two items that are not in House
Bill 25
they are from 2019 letter F
comprehensive monitoring for piscataqua
region estuaries that will lapse
and
from 2017 letter C clean water srf State
match
unlike all the other clean water srf
State matches that we have one of them I
see you want apps but those two are are
yeah that's 17 letter c
okay correct okay with that the floor is
yours to say whatever you would like
thank you and thanks for having us back
it seems like it was only Friday I was
here for some of you uh so again
hopefully you have the handout two
handouts uh well they're all one hand
out with a table at the end uh so
hopefully you'll you'll agree with me I
uh Sue Carlson's put together uh she's
listed listed uh this the the
appropriate sections for House Bill 25
where appropriate and uh
the state law but also uh what you'll
see in the handout here as as the
Preamble says the first sentence uh uh
she's tried to group this by by subject
matter so you'll see all the dams listed
together so uh so I'll go through these
quickly again I have the brains of the
outfit with me here Sue Carlson so
she'll probably it'll be very easy to
stump the chump if you will by asking me
a question but hopefully uh I know
should be able to do that so uh quickly
I'll go through uh the the handout we
had uh which talks about section 94 91
for hazardous waste so this is the 10
percent match that we're required to do
for federal Superfund sites so this this
the the listed sites here uh are New
Hampshire plating and Merrimack Colin
Colin achesman Aikman in Farmington and
the Savage administrable uh well site in
in Milford uh so again I can go into
date detail but again this is the
coverage the 10 cost match
uh for that so at the Mr chair I don't
know if you want to you just keep me
keep going or okay
so uh then
our Center Mills uh just this is for the
the new committee members uh Des has put
this package together that he given us
their section numbers 94 91 81 things
like that correspond to our line numbers
in this worksheet package so if you're
wondering where the Hazardous Waste made
and when it's they say section 94 go
right to your worksheet it's line number
94. it's item number 94. thank you thank
you thank you
thank you so going to section 81 I guess
would be line 81 uh is for the again
we've we've lumped the state revolving
loan funds together as we discussed
um
uh on Friday so we're required to do a
20 match for uh most of our srf
requirements again Friday we mentioned a
couple uh out of the infrastructure Bill
uh that are different but but in this
case we're talking about the drinking
water uh
uh State revolving Loan Fund and uh and
typically so you'll find basically the
same narrative for the Clean Water uh
srf and the drinking water srf so these
projects take multiple years to actually
complete uh it which is why you you'll
see some some of them on a lapse as we
move forward again I can go into detail
for any of these but but as as uh are
articulated uh we can only all in the
handout we can only close these projects
out
at the completion of construction so you
have to you know obviously have design
all the way through to construction uh
and getting these loans done uh so again
as I mentioned so that's section 88 and
79 or lines 88 and 79 are are basically
the similar again for for the
uninitiated clean water is waste water
and storm water projects uh those
actually tend to take even longer than
drinking water projects wastewater
treatment facilities that type of thing
uh again if there's no questions I'll
move on to lines 86 and line 80. so this
is uh Dam reconstruction and repair
uh so we're here we're talking about
2019 funds uh in the encumbrance of
those
um again what we've seen is some delays
in some of the work we we would like to
have done uh for Dam repairs uh due to
due to covert covid and Associated uh
supply chain uh material shortages uh in
particularly when you go to the the
second half of that paragraph you'll it
talks about uh fiscal year 21 and the
remaining uh funds for that and that
that is for ongoing work uh at cops pond
dam in tuft tomorrow uh which we expect
to be done uh earlier this year and uh
kilton pond dam and Grafton and we're
we're seeing we're expecting it to start
construction at the Highland Lake Dam
and starter and
and design work on Pawtuckaway uh dams
will be starting this summer so as a
kind of a factoid the design work we
typically do as a discreet thing before
we obviously before we start
construction but that that's uh you'll
understand a necessary thing to be done
first
uh
represent me
so I guess I'm confused you guys did a
reconstruction of the dam and Stoddard
on Highland Lake within 10 years or so
you just did a building a dish uh onto
the
property in the last three years what
else are you doing there
you know typically we do these this work
in phases so I I may have to
phone a friend of Randy Pelletier if if
you would like so yeah I'm not sure I
think they're still Spillway work we
were looking at but you're going to
thank you
I appreciate your
your your interest in that particular
so uh keeping on the topic of dams
generally so we were very pleased to
have a new facility and on silk Farm
Road Ted cover's not here I would I
would I'll thank him in his absence
anyways you know uh admin Services
Public Works did a great job uh there's
a fairly large project uh just to brag
on that for a little bit for years we've
we've had a facility on on a river
uh we're where we've just vacated and uh
a lot of the it was a little bit very
dilapidated very old historic though uh
and we a lot of our materials in case of
a flood and emergency were stored there
well the problem with that is among
other things is in a flood zone so that
seemed kind of
counter-intuitive and maybe not smart uh
so this this facility is is a new on uh
silk Farm Road we're very pleased with
it uh it it not only includes
um the damn Bureau uh operations and and
maintenance uh uh facilities there place
for their trucks and whatnot but also
for our Watershed and emergency response
uh cleanup also so it's a great facility
I say all that my intention is my hope
is sometime when the weather clears this
spring early summer to do some kind of
ribbon cutting there so if you're so
interested we would love to have you
um we're very proud of it uh so any case
uh so that so lines uh 87 and 92 have to
do with that the remaining
Appropriations is really for cleanup as
we finish up any last punch items on the
punch list items on that building
uh line 93 is for the Ossipee Lake Dam
that's another cleanup issue uh that was
a a great project I think for Ossipee
Lake we actually use the old Dam uh as a
basically a coffer Dam while we've we
constructed the the new one uh lake oski
is very flashy so this was uh we had to
lower the level probably more than some
of the boaters will like but uh as as we
reminded them that's better than the
alternative which is not to do the
maintenance and not to have the water
there uh but any case uh this this was a
good project also and uh again the
remaining monies being used to do some
some cleanup uh uh around that Dam uh as
far as uh punch list items uh including
the scada system for instance
um a line 95 uh is uh again this is a a
a fairly ongoing project so it's it
stemmed from the the 2006 uh
issues with this the Suncook River where
it jumped its Bank uh so that's by and
large uh mostly done as you drive down
Route four depending on the direction
you're going you can you can see the
armoring of the bank uh in that uh
that's taken a little bit longer to
totally finish uh there's the the the
the the soils and whatnot on that river
river bank where they have armored it
are have not been completely stabilized
the sinkholes and that type of thing
have developed so this is ongoing work
to to finish that up
uh line 90 and 82 uh have to do with our
our One-Stop system and and we had uh
for those who were here we had assistant
commissioner uh Sanborn talking to that
um on Friday so we've issued an RFP we
we expect
um
you know within a few months here we'll
have we'll have obligated These funds uh
as we move forward
uh section 97 uh it has to do with
[Music]
um
air monitoring equipment or flood
forecasting or stream gauges and some
database up upgrades uh so again that
work is underway
uh section or line uh 98 84. uh again
Friday uh we talked about the
Winnipesaukee River Basin uh so again
this is not General funds and and uh
comes out of the user fees and this is
for
projects uh on those systems so again we
have 13 pump stations in the wastewater
treatment facility itself so uh as you
may imagine aging infrastructure uh
takes money to repair uh and replace
uh and I think I'm getting to the end
and then we have a
we have an Easter egg at the end here so
uh that's coming soon here we're going
to suggest we give some money back
um so then we have coastal flooding uh
which modeling which is uh lines 83 and
85.
uh and that's uh
that project was delayed due to due to
getting the right data set to go with
that so that's moving forward but we are
delayed on that so that's that's why
that's listed and as I mentioned uh
on page seven of the handout uh we have
suggested you'd there'd be a deletion uh
and and to we're asking for a lapse of
funds uh as you see here regarding to
one of our natural resources
conservation service dams uh and the the
real issue not that we wouldn't love to
have money for that but there basically
we're not ready for that construction to
be done yet so we're kind of out of
cycle in advance so that's that's that I
don't know if so you want to talk to the
two issues the chair mentioned I'm
trying to
try to remember the the two
the 2017 no no no we're all set okay we
didn't put them on the list because
they're fully expensive okay all right
all right so with that if there's
certainly any questions or I can
elaborate more or or less hopefully for
you I don't know thank you I'll just
point out to the committee that the uh
on the section 96 slaps would uh free up
and representative Mills thank you Mr
chair this is just once again for the
new people on this that doesn't don't
know exactly how to follow along
what we've basically done is gone
through items 75 I'm sorry 79
through 98 in our handout
and the only one that we are they're
requesting to keep all their lapses keep
all their money going with the exception
of line 96 where we're going to recover
1.155 million dollars
so 89 we're going to delete that's fully
expended
and representative Boyd thank you Mr
chairman commissioner and director
Carlson thank you very much very quickly
in a slightly parochial request is it
possible to get an update on the New
Hampshire plating site in Merrimack
just where where we are and how far
we've come
that would be wonderful thank you so
much
thank you Mr chairman seeing no further
questions was there anything else you
wanted to say
well thank you very much for coming
we want to keep our dams in good repair
because obviously many of them there's a
life safety
component to having it fail so thank you
very much for doing that
and our representative Eden
just on the the sun cook River didn't
when that did the flood didn't that take
a new Trail or a new Direction and did
you have to stay with the New Direction
do you have to go back to the old
Direction order to do a divided split
yep
yep it jumped
and has gone on and you had to stay with
the New Path and when that happened
because of the floodplain there were a
significant amount of buyouts by FEMA
right some 24 people took money and left
their property because it's in the
floodplained so it's been a really
successful project and once they
stabilize the sinkhole of the plant
vegetation more vegetation and hopefully
it's going to put some closure on that
thank you that always tried to remember
to find out what happened because that
was a
significant
thank you I'll just remind everyone this
this is going out over live stream so no
one on the live stream heard that answer
because the gentleman is not at a
microphone
you try to paraphrase if you like but
for the for the listening audience so
again the the river had jumped its banks
for the for the most part we've it the
question was did it we follow the old
try to keep it on the old path of the
New Path and the short answer is uh it's
still following A New Path and there
were some buyouts from FEMA for roughly
25 properties uh that were in the flood
plain and and again so that this project
the remaining monies are to uh continue
to stabilize and do plantings uh again
we're getting it was a very challenging
location to try to stabilize that
portion of the river uh near the bridge
a chair just a brief question
please representative Jarvis thank you
you talked about scada earlier in one of
the line items and do you have a control
point where you have monitoring the dams
and is there you got scada I'm guessing
you have alerts and maybe some video
real time
uh all that's more more for the future
most of our dams do not uh I think we
have what six seven right now uh the
recipe is getting it uh as we speak
that's one of the things they're they're
still refining uh so you know as we move
forward we're looking at more use of
more video that we can see remotely uh
and securely uh and uh obviously the
skate a part of that also which is why
you know we we have stream gauges that
type of thing and those those
Integrations are important moving
forward but by and large there's what
600 and I mean 200 over 260 or so
state-owned dams I think it's actually
higher than that and very few of them
have uh Control Systems uh as you
discussed although I think that's needed
moving forward
thank you and um
is so just briefly
for the ones we'll monitoring now that
goes back to
a point or a place in your office where
you'll see the alarm
seeing nothing further thank you very
much for coming
all right the hour being 10 30. uh we
can reconvene the subcommittee with the
Department of Corrections we have Helen
Hanks the commissioner and John Hanson
um good morning good morning and for the
record again Helen Hanks uh commissioner
of the Department of Corrections to my
right is John Hanson our director of
administration
um so we're happy to sit and talk with
you about projects that are previously
funded and their status and I'll turn it
over for John to take the lead on that
good morning
so we have a handout which I think
everyone got around I'm actually on page
two but it is numbered one at the bottom
and these are our existing capital
budget projects as we have them now and
on the right hand side is listed the
actual budgeted amount from the
beginning from the house bill 25s from
over multiple bienniums that contain
that money so the first one the exterior
door Replacements that first item there
that is a one that's going to lapse is
about 79 in that one which is going to
go to lapse
um the second one is a door project
which is going to be going out this
summer and that's to complete the
exterior doors and for those of you
won't on the committee at that time we
have a substantial number of exterior
doors at that facility which are rotted
out at the bottom due to salt and sand
and everything else we've done to them
and it just we need to replace them this
is the one that I cannot find in House
Bill 25
so if we can find out the line when that
one that you don't want to lapse was
appropriated
sure
so I'm sorry on page nine uh the section
about halfway down
oh okay so you're looking at this here
uh boiler replacement store controller
upgrades
what I have is a door replacement in 19
letter f
that is not listed in House Bill 25 so
wood lapse and another door replacement
in 17 letter e that is also not listed
and would lapse
okay on the sheet that was just handles
would be number 67 which is the the next
oh all right
so the one that is not lapsing is from
2111.
correct
this is the what we did initially on
this one is some of you may remember we
went out at a hundred thousand dollars
each at first and thankfully you folks
upgraded that to two hundred thousand
dollars on those doors
so there was three separate times we
have some money for that over a period
I can continue the body alarm you all
set with that one thing so the body
alignment camera project that one was
the um
two million six hundred twenty five
thousand dollar project that will
continue in the last page of this I'll
go over the continuances kitchen
renovation and design 4.3 million
electrical service 265 000 perimeter and
security defense detection systems this
top section if you haven't found already
these are all for just a Concord Men's
prison
um 1.6 million roof Replacements various
roofs 1.8 million boiler Replacements
2.1 million
uh Heating and Cooling uh
cooling coil Replacements 125 000 the
sewer grind is 670 000 steam lines 2.5
million roof Replacements 2 million
uh air handle and duct work that's the
arpa funded project and that was
increased and now it's at 3.2 million
CCU door and ceiling replacement repairs
300 000 and the medium custody you know
South bathroom project which is
completed 650 thousand dollars
um I will just add on all of these
projects we've had to get very creative
and we've had to downscale what we
initially intended
um just to one typical example a project
is done the medium custody north south
bathroom was 24 bathrooms when we
originally got estimates the concept was
replaced all fixtures all tiles all
showers epoxy the floors when we got
right down to it we only had money and
we had to negotiate with a low bidder
for 16 bathrooms and we used the
existing
fixtures in that those bathrooms and put
in new showers and epoxy the floors
through value engineering we're able to
do I believe 20 total bathrooms out of
that project so there's still four
bathrooms we couldn't even touch that's
just an example of what we had to do to
make sure that we got as much done as we
can versus coming back to two or four
years later saying you know that money
you gave us a couple years ago we need
another x amount of money we're seeing
that more and more and then the bottom
section of the projects in Berlin roof
Replacements at a million dollars dual
controller upgrades door controller
upgrade is different to the other door
projects just so you'll know the Dual
controller upgrades is most our doors
run on a system where there's a solenoid
you push a button it goes through a
solenoid and out and opens a door either
pneumatically or electrically and those
systems in Berlin need to be upgraded
they have a life of about 20 years and
we're right there now so this was an odd
one though we actually got ahead of it
and then the door started to fail so
it's a good thing we got that money in
place quickly and then the Primitive
security defense detection systems in
Berlin that's a big one 1.5 million and
that will include a fence line which has
some sinkholes uh where the the fence is
actually uh you can crawl underneath the
back of the fence so just put it that
way
in a prison that's not a good thing
um access road project was completed and
again that was scaled back we intended
to pave the entire parking lot and we
only were able to do the access road and
part of the Perimeter Road and some of
the drainage
and the last one is the construction
trades building
in the following Pages it gets in a more
granular detail I don't know how much Mr
chairman you want to do on this but I
can go over anything you want on any of
these projects in in as much detail as
you'd like
well I'm a little concerned that we
don't have the that that we haven't
correlated the lines that are lapsing to
what's still going on so if you'll
indulge for me
uh
we learned that we should delete
our line 73 the body alarm man down
system because that's complete
no that's not complete uh so we've asked
for that to be extended um
that that's the project is completed
from the contractor standpoint there's
about three hundred thousand dollars
left and in order to finish what we need
to finish we're buying those products
outside of the contractors purchase
process which includes a substantial
markup
um I don't want to it's over 15
um much over it I believe so we're
buying a lot of those components
ourselves and we've asked for that to be
lapsed next time around all right so the
initial information we had was we were
going to delete 73 but now uh we're not
the body line our policy would be to
leave it there unless we're absolutely
sure that every bill for the project has
been paid
right at the moment we're sitting here
at the moment sitting here I don't
believe no it's not so I will leave that
in that's not an issue
um the electronic controls and security
camera installation from 17 letter f
uh is not in the house bill 25.
we're definitely not we're definitely
not working on the same sheet of music
with you today and we apologize in
advance
yeah we're working on what we're working
on it's not an item that's why it would
lapse unless we do something to put it
in
nope
well the problem is these are not in
possible 25.
I guess even in so our exterior door
we were simply working off the
governor's proposed
um capital budget which is our section
is on page nine of his proposed capital
was there anything else you wanted to
say I what I'll do is after we break
I'll go through my list and we'll check
it
because there appear to be several
projects that are not in House Bill 25
so we can go I can go down just right
off the top of my head here on starting
on your page five I believe on your
capital budget lapse extension worksheet
um with item number 57 that one should
not lapse
that is one that hasn't even gone out to
bid yet yeah the first the first one
that would lapse is is between 71 and
so the electrical services number 71
that project starts this spring
so that that money needs to stay so we
can pay the contractor
um 72
uh that's that one has not uh started
work so that one would need to stay
that's 350 000 dollars
uh item number 73
is the one we just talked about and
that's the one that needs to stay
because we have money in there we're
going to buy our we are buying equipment
as we speak for that
um and I'm talking about well components
to that system
uh and then 74.
it starts at the
top of that is Department of Education
yeah okay so the so I have from 19
letter D generated replacement that is
not in house bill 25.
oh okay back on the beginning of the 19.
uh
I think it's 19. that's right we talked
about letter E the access road that
so we're not looking we're looking at
page two the item 19 that's administered
these are items that are that were
appropriated that are not in House Bill
25 and would lapse unless we add them
and what I'm trying to do now is make
sure that the projects are complete and
can lapse
okay I guess the easiest way to do this
from uh everyone's standpoint if you
flip to the back page of our
presentation
these are the items that we have as
lapsing so the exterior door
Replacements the one we talked about
medium custody north south bathroom
renovation we talked about
the generator Replacements and the
access road project were the four that
we have on our list as as uh being able
to lapse and that money go back to the
fund
everything else on that list would stay
and I could we could
um probably take a minute and correlate
all that back to your worksheets all
right I have one well they're not on the
worksheet because they're not in house
bill 25.
so in uh the governor's proposed which
as you say it would be House Bill 25.
we're satisfied with what's on page nine
okay
yeah there's nothing on there that that
word concerns us there's nothing that's
[Laughter]
I wish I'd had that I uh we're all
looking at different things through this
through this time frame uh frame trying
to determine what we have for laughs
representative bogert
uh thank you Mr chairman uh
could you please go ahead and correlate
that page 20 I noticed there's some
whichever color you call them yellow
that are lapsing can you give me the
coordinates to
which item numbers of the yes please yes
okay
we start
yeah we'd have to pull up the I don't
have the uh I have apparently confused
the committee uh if a the reason you're
not finding them in hospital 25 is
because they're lapsing
okay
the flaw would be if there were a
project that was ongoing that was
inadvertently omitted from houseboat 25
and needs to be added because it's still
ongoing and otherwise they wouldn't be
able to spend the money that okay I'm
I'm seeing my head's got around this now
so they have told us that there is
nothing that needs to be added to House
Bill 25
and so these items in yellow are
projects that are complete so there is
no number in hospital 25 that they
sure
so everything that we have in House Bill
25 items 57
Rue
73 you wish to have extended yes
yes see thank you
thank you
Friday
[Laughter]
and they're they're in uh
in an item uh
well the item the generator item there's
seventy thousand dollars that we can use
yes
that was one we did with owned forces we
didn't go to public works I'm sorry we
did not go through public works on that
project and that was so I were able to
I could go through any of these in
detail if you want to know why we have
some of these projects still continuing
but whatever information you need we had
uh given that with Hospital 25 is
correct as it stands uh
That's How we'll leave it
excellent
thank you everyone we're we apologize
for not seemingly be so prepared today
I apologize for confusing the committee
and trying to go into an area that I
shouldn't have been
well that well till we meet again we'll
all be on the same page
representative Gilman
tanned out from today I don't see why
not all right thank you
[Music]
comment is uh an addition to be built
adjacent to the existing kitchen
so that's going to
mean it it seems as though the very
little bit that I know about the
facility that kitchen
that I don't think you can do much more
with it and congratulations on the tarp
system that has whatever so this would
be an adjacent
thing that will be serviceable for maybe
the next few years until you get them
yes representative excellent question
um our plan would be at this point um if
House Bill 2 goes through and the
additional money is allocated to build a
new Men's prison we actually won't be
doing that two floor additional prison
outside uh prison kitchen outside that
area into the prison yard that's going
to be something that we would maintain
at an existing location using the
additional money the money that we have
allocated now to renovate existing in
place we're going to be working hand in
hand with public health to make sure we
do it right to get through to the next
phase which would be building a new
facility so we need another 7.1 million
dollars on top of the 4.3 to do that
freestanding kitchen that will not need
to happen now if we go this route
safe to say if hb2 and the money
allocated as the governor's contemplated
passes we won't be back to ask for more
money we're just going to try to shore
up the space until a new facility is
built if a new prison is not built we
will need an additional seven plus
million dollars to build this two-story
structure
on top of the existing 4.3 allocated so
over 10 million dollars to build a
kitchen
thank you for that question
representative Edgar
okay I just have a couple questions
thanks
um
I gather from the summary a minute ago
all everything listed in the uh in in
House Bill 25
you want to continue to to have open and
then but the question I have is with
your list here
if you have on the last page of your
presentation there's some items are we
going to get money back from any of
these
projects that have shown
um did it I guess they would be ones
that are not listed in here but you've
completed and
it's a little confusing thanks thank you
representative Edgar and I apologize
again for the confusion the projects
listed on page one are also listed on
page 20. and on page 20 the items that
are yellow or shaded those wood laps
those monies would go back to the dermal
fund everything else that's in white
we're asking for continuation to
continue to shore up those projects as
we navigate okay
like to continue then so
someone which the items here that we're
going to get money back for what do they
relate to that's in hb25 it's not
they're not there because we did not ask
for them to continue in any way shape or
form okay so I'm just trying to figure
out is before getting money back
how much is it
um but how are we going to do that is it
uh don't we have to have it in here and
then what we will do is we will add
language if we decide to use this money
we will add language to hospital 25 that
lapses this amount and then reallocates
it to another project if you were to
look back at the bill we passed in in
2021 there's a couple examples of that
there are but that I realize that that's
what we're going to do in this case so
we're going to gain some money from this
thank you the money doesn't actually
come to the general fund it's bonded
indebtedness that was never spent
so it can go into bonded indeedness for
something else so roughly 76 thousand
dollars
representative new one yes just a a
follow-up if I remember correctly I
looked at the large
white uh request book last week for a
little while
are there there are and I believe I saw
for the Department of Corrections for
the new prison there was a low a Midway
point and then a high number for a an
estimated projected cost is that correct
in the presentation we shared uh last
week we showed you our work we did with
the state treasurer to ascertain What
bond ratings would look like because we
were doing that exploration and we have
been we just wanted to share that back
to the committee that we were being
mindful about how would the state do
you're talking about the slide in the
last presentation no I'm I'm talking
about a a page in the whatever you call
that big white book that's in that room
over there
um I I looked at notes on the bottom and
it seems that there were three numbers
for a proposed new prison cost a lower
medium and a high number so where I'm
going is I'm hoping that nobody says
well let's put the loan number in and
approve that if that's just a wish list
representative Newman you're absolutely
right and at this point I think all of
our experience with projects tells us we
were doing our best estimating at the
time right and the high number is the
safer number to go with at this point
Thank you you're welcome thank you for
the question
I'll just point out that at this moment
it's not this committee's task to
appropriate that money there's another
committee down the hall that is working
on that so
uh
that that's not up to us to determine
well thank you for coming if there are
no questions and
we'll say anything else thank you very
much for coming thank you everyone have
a great week and be safe tomorrow our
next committee what's our next committee
is Health and Human Services at 1 pm
so we're going to be in recess until
then
foreign
the cleanup will be done overnight all
right the last time I looked it looked
like the snow was supposed to stop about
nine o'clock Tuesday night Tuesday night
we'll all be over it's supposed to start
tonight is rain
that's why they can't figure out how
much right it's going to be snow
once it's going to start tonight around
eight nine o'clock as rain and then
whenever it changes over to something
what's going to go where you are in the
state
yeah yeah that's right now they're
saying Nashville around noon tomorrow
starting with snow so I'm assuming where
you you're a dairy man yeah so you're
probably gonna Dairy is looking for snow
the hour being one o'clock we'll
reconvene the committee and we'll
welcome the Department of Health and
Human Services and we have we were the
commissioner and Nathan white the Chief
Financial Officer
and we apparently don't have you do not
have to worry about them so my name is
Chris santanello I'm an associate
commissioner at the Department of Health
and Human Services
my name is David Wieters I'm the
information Services director for
Department of Health and Human Services
so great thank you very much please uh
whatever you want to cover please do
sure um so I think I think Chris did
hand out a um worksheet and basically
the department we are closing out 13
projects this fiscal year with a total
um lapse amount of
4.4 million 282 557.
um which we would like to request an
amendment to House Bill 25 to utilize
just about 1.4 million dollars
um for the Glencliff wastewater
treatment improvements needed to avoid
compliance violation and emergency
repairs
um and then the remaining 19 capital
projects we are requesting that the
funds of about 112 million 695
339 do not lapse so that we can continue
to work on those projects in the next
biennium
those I believe are in
House Bill 25 starting in section 12
and our goal was to not necessarily
spend a lot of time on each project but
leave it to the committee task specific
questions if you have and right now
um Christopher Shea Justin
requested that I do a crosswalk between
hb25a as introduced with the pro the
line numbers like 10 101 through 120 for
our handout so I'm putting that together
to resubmit I actually just finished
that so maybe we can do it
as we go
so why don't we go through the projects
that you want to lapse and I'll identify
the line numbers
okay so the first project that we have
on the handout is the New Hampshire
hospital air upgrades and Ellen I'm not
sure if you want me to bring you up
do you want Dave just to go through that
and if you have questions on the
projects we can bring people up
does that work well all right I'll walk
through what we saw for dotes and this
is going to be line 117 that you would
request to delete
yes so on line 117 there's a remaining
amount of one thousand two hundred and
eighty dollars that is not encumbered
that we would be looking to lapse the
encumbered amount of 11 282 which is the
remaining fund we is still uncovered on
the contract and we need to complete the
contract for that
and then the next project electronic
visit verification system which I
believe is line 104 that's line 104.
thank you on that project specifically
we have a planned amount
um for the contract to expend through
the next fiscal year
um looking at a partial lapse of 3.71
million or 3 million seven hundred and
ten thousand dollars this is the project
that we would we would request either
one of two options either
adding additional scope to this project
to support the glencliffe waste
Wastewater Treatment Services or utilize
it the the lapse amount to be re
appropriated for the Glencliff
wastewater treatment
I can't speak for the full committee yet
but I would imagine we would want to add
it as a line item and then add language
when we present our findings
the the next project is the auto mailing
system and this one is already not in HP
25.
foreign
so that one we we only have 394 dollars
left in the account and
um that we would look to we were
assuming wood laps and there's an
existing encumbrance of
6276 that would be
the next line item is the access tunnel
that's Line 120 in HP 25.
thank you
in this one we're looking to lapse the
remaining amount of 36 654 dollars
that is I mean one
twenty one twenty six
thank you
and and this one as you see in our notes
the last payment was was processed
subsequent to this biennial budget and
we would be expecting to lapse the
remaining amount of 3883 dollars
the next one is the electronic health
recording
that's line
128 128
and this project is
complete as well and we would be looking
to lapse five thousand nine hundred and
the next project is the Glencliff water
that is already not in hb25
so the the actual encumbrance of
5984 dollars will be liquidated and then
lapsed
that is line 125.
and this project
um
through is complete and we would be
lapsing
the next project is the Howard Rec
Auditorium
foreign
[Music]
121.
thank you
and that project is complete and we
would be lapsing 25 711 dollars
the next one is the New Hampshire
hospital electronic
and
it's also from the same year
that is 123
and that that project the current
encumbrance will need to be finalized to
close out the project however the
remaining balance of twenty six thousand
two hundred thirteen dollars would be
lapsed
the next project is Barn boiler
replacement
what year is that from 21 that is the
2223 budget but the
it was for the it was initiated in 2021
um funded in 2021
let me see if I can find it
oh here it is that is already not in HP
25.
okay and that project actually was
canceled as it was identified as not
being cost effective as the the location
where the boiler was is like the roof is
needed is leaking and needs to be
repaired so we canceled that project we
did have initial costs um expended for
the site prep and everything but the
remaining amount of 78 500 would be
lapsed
the next project is the mmis tech
and that project is complete as of
August 2021 and the remaining amount of
362 108 dollars it shall be lapsed or
should be lapsed
then the last project on our completed
foreign
and this project
is complete and the remaining amount of
fifty one thousand four hundred and
and if we go to the remaining projects
that we'll go through are the projects
that we have not completed and we would
be requesting to not lapse the funds the
representative bogert uh just a quick
question to you Mr chair there was the
Glenn Cliff water for five thousand nine
hundred and eighty four dollars
which was on the I didn't catch what
there's a
person the uh there's a project from
2015 line a glencliffe home portable
water system that is not present in HP
yep there is a phase two which I would
assume he will get to that was
you are correct well it is still
underway
so the next project is the demo Wilkins
building
and I believe it's um line 110.
correct
and that project is still ongoing and
with the planned completion of April
30th 2023
and the full the the amount of 701 325
is currently encumbered and we plan to
yeah
okay the next project is the dcyf c c w
i s or Child Care child child child care
welfare information system and I believe
and that project is that specific
project was associated with a six-year
total product project timeline it's
years three and four which was funded
for this this biennium
and due to some regulations with our
Administration for children and families
and our procurement practices we have as
well as the um
some of the pandemic impacts on our
resources that has been delayed and
we're looking to complete the first four
phases
and then the overarching whole content
project would be completed June 30th
2026.
the next project which is on line 106
um it says Mars e in security assessment
that project is
um with a completion date of June 30th
2024 it is on track to complete on that
time frame we initially had an
expectation of completing it this June
um but due to Resource uh resource um
reductions in in allocations towards the
pandemic response were about a year
behind
the next project is the new heights Inc
and I haven't found the number on that
that project is still still in progress
we are near completion we estimate a
June 30th 2024 completion subsequent to
the federal Public Health Emergency
unwind and some additional eligibility
components for the dental program that
the next project is a beneficiary
service improvement project and I
and that project is part of a
overarching Medicaid enterprise system
strategy reprocurement strategy and we
are actually in the process of
negotiating some contracts to roll out
two components of this solution with the
estimated completion of June 30th 2026.
foreign
the next project
is the federal reporting integration and
compliance line 105.
and I haven't been saying this but for a
total amount of 6 million seven hundred
fifty thousand dollars that project has
not been started due to the team
dedicated to move this initiative
forward was delayed as they were working
on some Medicaid other Medicaid programs
to support
with the goal of completing the RFP in
the next 12 months and then implementing
over the next couple years with uh May
the next project is the mmis lifecycle
management this one's also a combined
effort with the and it's on line 107. I
apologize combined effort with line 101
the beneficiary service improvement to
reprocure the Medicaid management
information system this project had an
original appropriation of 90 million
dollars we spent
a portion of that a total 24 million
dollars on the hardware and software
upgrade for the system to
to maintain and operate that solution
over the next five years as we replace
those components in a modular strategy
utilizing center for Medicare and
Medicaid services
guidelines
the estimated completion date for that
the next project is the beas which is
Bureau of elderly adults Services
systems modernization on line 108.
and that amount is
6795 427 dollars
this project is really dependent upon a
project that I'm going to speak about in
a moment the developmental I.T remote
developmental Services I.T remediation
project that has a goal a goal to go
live of this summer
and then as we do that what we
identified is that instead of building
three or four different systems we're
going to continue to expand that one
solution to manage this system's
modernization for the elderly Adult
Services as well as some other
developmental Disability Services as we
go forward
so as a result it's a sequential
implementation and they are different
modules so this this project is delayed
to September 30th 2024.
foreign
the next project
which indicates replatt op app and I
don't know I know what this one is and
I'll tell you about it but I'm trying to
find the number this is uh line 129 it's
from 2011 re-platform option application
so on line 20 129 this is a re-platform
of our options application which is the
application that supports elderly Adult
Services and it is combined with that
that line 108 as well as the
developmental I.T remediation which is
line 103 that we'll talk about next
the reason why this one actually hasn't
encumbered any funds was as as we went
through an Enterprise systems
architecturally identified that we were
building four or five different systems
and actually repeating costs so we're
trying to reduce our costs over time
and we anticipate this project being
completed in September 30th 2024
with a goal of looking across all these
trying to lapse some of the funds we
don't know exactly what they are until
we get the rfps out and completed but we
anticipate it being less than what it
the next project is line 103 for
developmental I.T developmental Services
I.T remediation
this is the project that sort of kicked
off the rest of them it was funded for
this biennium
and it was based off a strategic
directions of how do we how do we
address the developmental disability
services that we offer not only from an
I.T system but programmatically which
really kicked off a strategy of how that
impacted these other capital projects
that we're speaking about today
this project is anticipated to go live
this summer however there will be
additional enhancements and work done
through September 30th 2024 to finalize
the next project is Project 109 and or
line 109 for BDS direct billing
and this is the fourth of those projects
all together
um bds's Bureau of Developmental
disability services or developmental
services oh sorry Bureau of
Developmental services
and this is a the billing component
historically it was on a an access like
date database and with lots of excel
reports which in we're trying to
modernize and build off of the
developmental Services I.T remediation
so that we have a unified process for
billing
the the goal is tied to that
developmental Services I.T remediation
project 103 so that the delivery will be
the next project is on line 115 and it
should be developmental Services I.T
plan
and that one has a gold go live with
June 30th 2024 it
it again is associated with those other
projects and as you combine all these
together
you would have the total cost for not
just one system it's basically the
combination of four or five different
systems that are working with our area
agencies and and within our department
the next project is the new heights
modernization I don't have the line item
for that one
I have it it's uh 116.
thank you
so that project has a gold go live on
September 30th
um the reason why we said not to lapse
it does have an encumbrance of 112 200
and we do plan to spend the the total
amount that's available to complete this
work over the next
and as I said in many of the other
projects that particular team has been
really focused on the federal Public
Health Emergency and that caused a
severe delay in this biennium
as well as the previous and then in
previous bienniums we had some
we had asked some for several of these
projects to continue to not lapse due to
Resource constraints
um
so the next project
is the dcyf Child Welfare which is line
111.
and this was the first of three capital
requests for the comprehensive child
welfare information system
capital projects in in that system was
really incorporating four different four
or five different modules intake
assessment case reporting and then uh
claims processing
as part of that effort
um Department of Information Technology
and Health and Human Services partnered
on deploying a platform called
Salesforce
and from that perspective we we actually
needed to work with information
technology to build that foundation for
the solution prior to actually getting
the application running
I'll give an example of how that worked
so you understand these there's three
projects these two for TCU the c-west
they were from previous bienniums and
then the one that we presented on last
week those are the total amounts to
build on top of that platform that it
the I.T Department helped us build the
foundation for over the last several
years and we anticipate having a
contract completed this summer and
moving forward with a 6 to 18 month
timeline and we do anticipate having a
go live of this project on December 31st
2024.
the next one that we have is uh I
believe it's line 112 for Glencliff
water
it's like corn thank you
and that one is
that one is it was gold at completion of
June 30th 2025. we need to keep this
project open to really support the
remaining committed work to related to
that potable water system that we were
speaking about earlier on that other
project that we were we are lapsing the
funds on so this one we need to not
lapse the funds so we can complete that
work
the next project is the Chillers
um
and I don't know the number on that one
and that project was delayed as a result
of resource allocation to other
emergency projects but we do anticipate
completion June 30th 2025
we did start the work and we anticipate
that balance being spent by that
and then the next project is that nhh or
New Hampshire hospital Renovations and I
don't have the project for that one
that's 124.
foreign
essentially additional Plumbing
mechanical and electrical work needed to
complete that project with a gold
okay
and then the next one is the it's really
a New Hampshire Hospital campus security
or is it glencliffe
at glencliffe oh there's one for
Glencliff campus security glencliffe
number 119. thank you so 119 for
Glencliff campus security
that project was delayed but the plan
completion date is June 30th 2024.
and then the the last project that we
have on our list is the Glencliff
Electric
in its line 113.
and we anticipate that project to being
completed June 30th 2024 in in
leveraging the remaining funds on that
I am we we have a number of people here
from the Department that if there's any
specific questions that we well one
thing one thing I know I have a note
here that the electronic visit
verification is 90 Federal is this three
million dollar amount the general funds
or the total funds including the Federal
thank you that is the total funds that
including the federal funds oh so now we
only have 10 of that amount
thank you for the clarification you are
correct
so essentially the general fund
lapse would be closer to 371 thousand
dollars
that's item 104 if everyone is
representative Jack
um if I could could I just go through
your worksheet and identify what for
Health and Human Services would be
extended and then what would be lapsed
just so we're clear is the numbers that
need to be removed I'll go through the
notes that I have and if everyone can
cross-check me that would be great
so 101 stays 102 stays 103 stays 104
lapses although with a 90 smaller amount
than we thought
105 stays 106 stays 107 stays 108 stays
109 stays 110 stays
the barn boiler was already not there
uh that 111 stays 112 stays 113 stays
114 is deleted that's mmis technical
stack upgrade
one 115 stays Glencliff Fire Road was
already not there
uh New Heights so 116 stays
117 is deleted that's New Hampshire
automated inline mailing was already not
there
the glenkloof window replacement
118 is deleted
the glencliffe potable water system from
the campus security Glencliff stays
that's 119.
main access tunnel repair
120 is deleted
Howard wreck 121 is deleted
122 stays
123 the NH Hospital electronic health
124 stays
125 Glencliff ADA compliance is deleted
126 APS Security is deleted
127 stays New Heights modification uh
128 electronic health records is deleted
and 129 replatform option application
from 20 from 2011 stays
as do I and if if for some reason Health
and Human Services identify something
that should be different Dave will
and just one one more to add based off
of your notification your
noticing the electronic Visa
verification the the other project that
also is not full General funds on that
list is the 114 mmis technical stack
upgrade which again that was a 90
so instead of it being
instead of it being 362 108 for General
funding would be 36
210 or 211 dollars of laps
any further questions for the uh
representative Edgar
uh thank you Mr chair
so your note requesting uh
one million four hundred and thirty two
thousand uh
to be uh taken out of the the big amount
that we thought there was there is
that is correct
I will have to pull up the number to see
he's quicker with a spreadsheet than it
and do you and if I can and so do you
intend to try to uh use that money
that's that is existing there that is
lapsing there to go towards the uh the
project that you uh wanted to put it
yes we aren't able to do that without uh
modifying HP 25.
yeah I'm just asking what their intent
if I might as well I think that the
request from the Department which was
made last week as well is to fund this
project through repurposing
um they were hoping to provide you know
most of it if they could but I think the
request is still that the committee
consider this as a a part project to
repurposed funds too I'd also note that
the request last week was in the
neighborhood of 1.8 million so they've
and I will resubmit this to Mr Shea but
the based off of the calculations with
the 10 percent the total lapse that we
would be looking at is 617 660 dollars
is what I've got on my spreadsheet but I
will verify that and send it back to Mr
I mean
an erupting human
yes thank you on the subject system for
hello for the record my name is Todd
Bickford I am the executive director of
glencliffe home
thank you nice to see you yes is that
going to be a new system or a
replacement it's going to be a
replacement system the system we have is
a very Antiquated and doesn't meet the
current Des standards and eyes on the
verge of collapse which would add much
additional costs
okay we saw the pictures that were
dramatic
um and and I had asked last week also if
whoever was going to be doing the work
was familiar with the location of Glenn
Cliff I guess going back at least at
least one biennium I had spoken with
commissioner shibanat and because there
was concern that people were doing work
bidding on projects but weren't familiar
with the
rural ruralness of your location and
that was a problem so um she was making
sure that people were familiar with the
situation when they bid yes that's a a
comment over the past years issue um
people from out of state bidding on
something and then realizing where we're
located right we do have a couple of
vendors that frequently do projects for
us that we would make sure that they're
aware of any uh our feet have put out
and in addition we've worked with Public
Works to insist on a mandatory site
visit before the bids you know largely
just so that they realize how remote we
are right and just just one more on the
Windows you might not be the window
person but all of the the windows now in
the Lamont section
everything is in and yes nothing is
wonderful this this winter was much
warmer for the rest nothing blew in
nothing fell on the residence it was a a
very successful project that the staff
Jim if I could one quick question please
the uh the wastewater treatment
facility when do you want to begin on
this we hope to help start this spring
part of the reason we the number went
down from 1.8 to 1.4 and change is that
Des has some Arbor funds that they're
able to provide us as well to make up
that difference and we need to have that
encumbered I Believe by June 30th to get
that from them and then the project
would start either this summer or in the
fall somewhere do we have you have bids
in hand we should not have bids in hand
but we do have in hand is the design and
plans we had done a capital project I
want to guess six years ago to design a
new dementia wing and part of that
project included having Engineers look
at our current student system then to
upgrade it for additional capacity so
we've pulled those out of the out of
those plans and just having an engineer
review them and restamp them and that
should be completed within a week or so
okay thank you
anything further from anyone
representative Edgar
thank you Mr chair and thanks for taking
my question
on this particular project we just that
we're just talking about with the sewage
can you um do this somewhat modularly I
mean there's different components to it
so if you get a certain amount of money
you might be able to do a portion of it
or
thank you
not being an engineer I believe we could
and representative Juris thank you just
briefly
so what's the drainage
like now
very poor out of the four beds two are
still functioning and they take three
times as long as they should to drain
and those are the ones we're concerned
about overflowing I assume you guys saw
the council saw the pictures last week a
couple of beds are very overgrown the
other beds are not in much better shape
okay so so just your fear of draining I
mean sinks bathrooms
everything goes to those fields flowing
slowly
training slowly oh no fortunately we're
built on the side of the Hill
um so there's still plenty of
suction uh gravity suction down to to
the current system so it's not backing
up okay thank you thank you
okay anything further
all right if you could stay for just one
minute after we're done I have something
I want to raise
our our next agency is at two o'clock so
we'll be in recess until then and it
I will call the committee back from
Recess this is the Department of
military
and we have Warren Perry the Deputy
Commissioner and Judy Chen the Chief
Financial Officer
and uh
please feel free to say whatever you'd
like to
good afternoon uh Mr chair thank you for
the opportunity to testify members of
the committee so we're happy to be here
we provided a letter dated March 13th uh
signed by uh the adjutant general that
kind of goes over those uh those items
which we are asking for a lapse
extension for most of them are 100
federally funded uh and those things
that have General funds attached to them
don't amount to a lot of money and I
know that's our interest is to kind of
scrape back some of the money we can for
the general funds uh our intent is to uh
to do two things here today is keep all
of those things that uh we we would ask
to have a lab extension for and we'll go
through them and I'll answer any
questions you have on any of those and
then on page three of that letter you
can see the things that we will lapse in
terms of the amount of General funds and
federal funds that we intend to lapse
for this particular uh this particular
budget also I think that Mr Shea passed
out an addendum where we would like to
address one change to item
7166 and that you'll find that on the
bottom of page three and we just want to
repurpose that money into another
project
uh and I'll I think I'll start there one
of the things that happened at the end
of kovid was the Federal Government
waived the state match for some of their
federally funded projects
and in that time we used that 100
federally money that would have been
used where we would had to have used we
would have had to have used some general
funds to take care of some things and
now what we'd like to do is take that
appropriation and roll it over into
other projects uh
so it's about uh eight hundred and
ninety thousand dollars
uh and you could see that the current on
the top of that addendum that Mr Shea
passed out the current language that's
in the budget and what we would like to
change it to
essentially it's anti-terrorism Force
protection standards and some of the uh
some of the damage and decaying parts of
our buildings that are just aging that
we can keep the general upkeep we
anticipate that we'll get that done at
the end of next summer so about 18
so if so that's for the addendum piece
on the other the other items you can see
that those are all part of the HP HP 25
in uh the 23 20 uh 22 23 budget
uh the anti-terrorism force protection
pieces that were working at the Edward
cross training center in Pembroke uh and
stationing of the Regional Training
Institute with that project is underway
print it's it's the design is probably
pretty close to done
we're pending some federal project
approval 100 General funds to make that
happen it's about 1.6 million dollars
nine three two nine uh energy resiliency
and efficiency this is a real important
piece to us right now based on what's
happening in terms of keeping the lights
and heat on and the cost of energy
uh again we anticipate the fall of 24
completing that project
pending the federal government's
approval again 100 General funds
the Grafton County field maintenance
shop this is going to be in Littleton
the milcon was approved
for FY Federal fiscal year 24 we
anticipate completing that project in
the fall of 26 about 13 million dollars
almost 14 million dollars in federal
money
number 9331 minor military Construction
in kowas County
right so about nine million dollars in
construction and that's based on a
congressional earmark that we received
in this year's ndaa
that's the and it's going to be to
specifically to create a training
facility for power management for our
aviators in the White Mountains so this
is
training Pilots to fly and the
conditions in the White Mountains it
really is a training facility but there
is some there's some free chicken here
for the state as we will be able to
operate a little bit better in terms of
our uh search and rescue and the things
that we do to help people that are hurt
or or lost in the White Mountains so we
do a lot of that we save the state a lot
of money the federal government
subsidizes that as training so we're
able to save a lot of lives but a
relatively important project about
training power management and uh and
helping also with the state
with the state search and rescue
on page two 93 93 32
Stafford County minor military
Construction
Please Mr Mr chair uh I this isn't a
question I just want to let the the
newer members of the committee know this
because we've been having struggling
with this all day long
their presentation and their numbers are
in the exact order that we have them in
our capital budget in other words we're
on the Stratford County military
construction if you go down to number
um
on our sheet their next one
Warehouse facility upgrades will be 150
so that's where we're at if you're
trying to cross-reference their their
version with ours thank you
will they go in numerical sequence the
rest of the way through so yes so the
Readiness Center for renovation
yes correct alts number 150 I'll try to
everybody comes in with a different
version so we've got to figure out how
it matches to our version and again
easier to follow I apologize I've had I
known those numbers I would have just
those red uh so we were at uh 151 151 so
just allow for renovation alterations
the critical components of Reading
Center Statewide again most of our
infrastructure in terms of our Arena
centers aging and this just helps us
continue to keep that stuff serviceable
so we have good serviceable facilities
for our the members of the New Hampshire
National Guard that is uh a 50 50
project 50 Federal 50 General funds uh
these will replace a a boiler uh in
building F on the state military
registry reservation and the flooring in
the Manchester arena center which is uh
uh an aging facility but very useful to
us
there's only about 650 000 left on that
encumbrance we anticipate in the summer
of 24 we'll be able to complete that one
152 is a is land
everything uh that the state does with
regard to building facilities and
federal funding for facilities is uh
contingent on the state purchasing the
land to do so so this uh
this appropriation of five hundred
thousand dollars we anticipate
hopefully spending soon uh is to buy
land so that we can continue to build
new or uh have areas for our National
the land is 152 I thought
did I get the number right 152 yep
energy resiliency and uh
uh efficiency improvements in our
Readiness centers
so I don't think it would be lost on you
if I if I told you how much more energy
cost this year than it did uh last year
so this will help us kind of defray some
of the anticipated costs of of energy
just at peas and it won't necessarily
apply to this item but I could share
that we're paying about 285
000 a month to keep the lights and heat
on at peas
so PCR National Guard base it's not
again it's operating budget stuff so any
any money that we have to continue to
provide efficiencies will save us some
money in the long run and the payback
period on 800 800 000 that 800 000 won't
be very long at all if you think about
again land for military construction uh
that would be 154. Statewide acquisition
of lands
in the fall of uh
uh 23 we anticipate that again we're
looking at Parcels in Manchester Salem
and Concord as well as Pembroke right
now we're working through the you know
whether or not it's worth us making an
offer in Pembroke on two Parcels of land
owned by the utilities companies so
that's some of the things and there's
526 thousand dollars left on that
appropriation initially the next page
I'm sorry 155
that's why I brought my uh administrator
Finance I can't count generally so make
sure we get that right interrupt
please
yes I I might have been mistaken at some
point in time I think we went off the
tracks 154 which we just did land for
military construction on our sheet is
for the Concord Aviation Residence Inn
why don't you just go ahead and order
you're going and I'll figure and I'll
figure out the numbers later okay
again sir I apologize for the confusion
right so we'll talk about hazardous
hazard remediation that's where I'm at
top of Page Three
and that you're that's your number 156
I think it's we may be out of order with
you now right we're at absolutely out of
work
yep so we're out of we're out of order I
apologize we're I'm just going to keep
calling the title off and I'll pause so
you can find the appropriate place in
again this is uh we had some uh we there
were some existing soil that had may
have had some contamination on it so
what when we uh the reason this is we're
asking for the extension here is when uh
from 19 is when covid hit we were we
kind of ceased all spending on capital
projects to determine whether or not
we're going to need to reallocate money
so this this project got set aside for a
little while now that we have the
authority to spend the money we're re
we're bringing this back up to the top
so we'd like to keep these General funds
so that we can do this hazardous
remediation on the land so there were
some uh some lead contamination based on
what was before we owned the land a
makeshift firing range people with
sandpit that people would go shoot on we
just need to go do the remediation if
there is any uh any pieces there the
next the next project that I have is
Aviation Readiness Center and that's the
uh we anticipate here in the spring
we're going to be able to close this
project out adjacent to our Aviation
facility we built a new Readiness Center
for the aviation units uh there's only
about 28 000 left on this and we're just
working through the uh the process with
DPW to close out that project and make
sure there are no outstanding
contractual obligations with regard to
that project
the next project I have is federal and
Statewide repairs and upgrades
this would be csms Renovations under
construction in Manchester so that's the
uh it's a maintenance shop
uh and a copper a
cyber security
facility for our cyber security
organization in Concord
uh about four or five million dollars
left on that 15 million dollar
appropriation it's 100 federal funds we
anticipate in the win you know next
winter we'll have that complete
those are two pretty important projects
that cyber security one particularly so
for those who don't know the National
Guard has a cyber security unit cyber
warfare unit uh they're activated quite
often uh to go uh do both offensive and
defensive operations in the Cyber sphere
of things so they're doing great work
and it's pretty important
domain right now
they're pretty good
I I don't know exactly what they do I
mean I could if I went and asked but I
prefer to be blissfully ignorant but
Statewide minor military construction
yep
yep funny requested design and construct
a maintenance shop in Littleton
there's a
the design is underway construction is
anticipated to be awarded in September
Manchester anti-terrorism and force
protection that's one of the ones that I
want to highlight that was uh
funded 100 federally instead of the 50
50 that you see here on the shop so that
that 890 000 that remains we want to
repurpose and that would be the the that
addendum that uh that we made that I I
spoke about at the beginning of my
testimony
Grafton County Readiness design
Readiness Center design
we think the design is going to happen
in this Federal fiscal year and
construction will begin in 25 uh I
believe this is the the Plymouth
Readiness Center that uh they're going
to be working to to be done but this is
the design piece of that
so that's in terms of what's there that
we'd like to extend the lapse that's
that completes that part of my testimony
if you go to page the next page
uh
there was uh
uh almost two million dollars I'm
guessing that uh that we're happy to
lapse back and of that
about a hundred thousand dollars are
subject to your questions that concludes
so can we just cover so it's 1 167
that you would like to repurpose
I'm sorry 157
I don't know which number which number
is Manchester any terrorism Force
protection Renovations that is correct
sir uh is the one you'd like to
repurpose along the lines of what's on
this sheet here or the second sheet yes
so for the committee following Along on
our worksheet of 157 has the old
verbiage of what he wanted
and
and just to be precise representative if
you don't mind the top part of the
handout is the current 157. the bottom
only
Orson Newman
yes thank you um back to peas and the
energy did you say 275
000 a month
I I said I may have said 288 but it's
it's been averaging over 280 000 a month
for the last three months so the
kilowatt hour rate went from about up uh
and I don't I wish I had brought my
sheet maybe I did oh I did look at this
so in in June of 21 the kilowatt hour
rate was about seven and a half cents
seven seven point six cents at a
kilowatt hour
in February of 23 the rate was 48 cents
an hour
so usage went down and about a six-fold
increase in the kilowatt hour usage and
most of that was in transmission I'm
guessing
we anticipate that the rate for March is
going to be about 32 cents and then by
June back down to about 15 cents an hour
so our our usage rates in terms of
kilowatt hours are you know just for
comparison in June of 21 in that month
we used 587
000 kilowatt hours
and in February we used uh well let's
let's use April of 20 uh hold on let me
give you a better number
in October of 22 we used 482
but so our rates are staying pretty much
the same within about 40 000 kilowatt
hours a month this is probably the
standard deviation of that but to
kilowatt hour rate is just it sixth
honest it went six times more so we
anticipate that that'll go back down as
we go closer to the summer and we should
be back to more reasonable times we
anticipate
for March for April about 140 000 bill
so a little a little less than half
told any ability for any solar array or
have you looked into that so as a matter
of fact I met with the engine you know
it's not it's not an unusual question
representative so I thank you for it so
one of the questions we got yesterday in
the operating budget hearing was hey
have you thought about LEDs and every
time my light burns out we put LEDs in
so there are you know we we're doing the
very very best to to to to to save as
much energy as we can I can't speak to
solar but I would tell you probably the
installation of solar at this point for
would be almost cost prohibitive in the
short term and I don't know what the
payback period would be it sure would be
nice if we could all live in the green
world I I I'm not arguing that at all
but it's tough I mean and they have a
they have a pretty tough mission that I
think really what's driving this
increase in cost is the cost of
electricity mostly transmission so
thank you
what's the current status of the
proposal to redo the hangar you actually
have funds here
that are not carried are you are you at
all advancing that project is it dead in
the water
which which project well there was there
was in previous bienniums the ability I
know exactly what you're talking about
reconstruct the hangar at the airport
across the street so uh so that project
is based on so here let me give you a
little example of a little context of
what happened I understand your question
thank you representative so in the last
biennium we asked for an appropriation
to con construct a joint hanger with the
Department of Safety so that we could
house both our Aviation assets and safe
Department safeties uh specifically the
state police hanger co-located
as we went through the design part of
the project the design requirements for
the fire suppression systems for the
federal government were different than
the state and frankly the federal
government's requirements were cost
prohibitive right so this department of
safety would not have been able to
afford this and we wouldn't have been
able to afford it based on the cost of
the fire suppression systems so when we
realized that and we realized that there
was no way for us to be able to conduct
this Hangar joint construct this anger
jointly we came back to the committee
and asked for a rewrite a halfway
through the biennium to give the state
police or the department of safety back
their portion of that construction money
and we did that so we reallocated about
two million dollars back to the
Department of Safety so that they could
build their own facility and not be
waiting on the federal government to
fund the other half
as far as I know I'm not going to speak
for the Department of Safety but in our
conversations with the Department of
Safety their their intent is to
refurbish their current facility not to
construct a new one that's my
understanding again I can't speak for
the Department of Safety
from our perspective
the construction of the military part of
that Hangar is on hold until we get to
get the funding issue
it's a long explanation but I wanted to
I could share thank you sorry
representative Juris thank you
you've got some money budgeted for
resiliency and efficiency improvements
of 800 000 and you mentioned earlier
appease so is any of that going into
Renewables or is that just
um efficiencies for heating or or
replacement of like a lot you know
lighting or other electronics so if
thank you for the question so the most
of that I mean actually all of that will
go to the Army side not at peace and
it'll be focused on things like roofs
heating Windows efficient Windows
efficient uh uh HVAC systems heating
systems boilers but none of it will go
to peas their funding streams are a
little bit different at peace most of
their construction is 100 you know it's
taken it's federally done not it's not
done through the state budget
okay
and just one more land acquisition you
budgeted you elapsing it is that
have you gotten any prices from the
landowners that you will butt
so we we continue to look for land uh
avara Butters and one of them or
actually there are two Parcels in
Pembroke that about us that are owned by
eversource and Unitil I believe
we have a we have a kind of handshake
negotiated kind of price for one of the
parcels in uh in Pembroke and I believe
it's 140
000 I believe something close to that
for that that's I don't know the acreage
I'm sorry I don't have it off the top of
my head uh but that's that's the one
price that we have right now land right
now is really hard to find I mean we're
if I could expand on that answer uh the
reason why we have a land appropriation
is not because we want to buy a specific
parcel of a land that has been
identified
the reason why we have a land
appropriation and Carry It Forward is to
be able to purchase land if and when
it's needed the reason for that is
sometimes the federal government any any
military and I'm sure you'll correct me
if I don't have this quite right any
military construction has to be on state
land that they do
and
you cannot use federal funds to buy that
land so we have land appropriation in
reserve so that when they come and say
we'd like to build a Readiness Center in
this area they have the ability they
have the funds to buy land to put it on
without having to wait for an
appropriation cycle after which they
will have lost the federal funding that
they were offered do I have that about
right
it's very correct for the Army side peas
is a little bit different but it's
I
think it's more than pre-approval for
by that uh
though that wraps it up thank you
any anyone else
apparently no
all right well thank you very much thank
you very much for your time I'm happy to
so we're we're expecting an agency at 2
30 that is not here yet so we'll be in a
it being 230 we welcome the Department
and
this is not who is on the sheet but we
know who you are so if you would just
identify yourself so that we have that
on there good afternoon yes
um natural Inc this is the Department of
Natural and cultural resources
um good afternoon Mr chairman members my
name is uh Chris Moreno I'm the chief
Administration for the Department of
Natural cultural resources
and with me is Tom Mansfield our
department architect
um and if I just lead off of the just a
brief statement and then we can
discuss I appreciate that
as you're aware at dncr we currently
manage a number of capital projects
funded with capital Appropriations
awarded to us through this and the prior
biennium approved budgets
at this time we currently have 13 open
accounts containing Capital
Appropriations which is listed on pages
13 14 of the governor's capital budget
requests
that we have requested to be carried
forward for use in the 24-25 biennium as
we move forward to complete the projects
for which the Appropriations have been
provided
for some accounts progress on a small
number of these projects and thus use of
the funding has been delayed a reason
such as refocus of priorities and
redirecting of work resources
particularly during the 2021 biennium in
response to the demands brought on by
the covid pandemic for example or in the
recent biennium matters of logistics
such as needed planning changes and
other on-site matters which require
preliminary work efforts before Capital
infrastructure work can begin have
delayed use of the funds however we have
been able to proceed with much of what
has been budgeted and several are fully
encumbered and or very close to
completion
we're eager to move forward with
completion of all of the efforts for
which we have been approved for funding
and to that end request at this time to
be allowed to carry these funds as
listed forward into the new biennial
thank you and I'm happy to answer any
questions
there was one the uh
Communication System replacement letter
G you wanted to have added do I
understand that yes there was a
remaining amount of an old Communication
System replacement
fund that still had eighteen hundred
dollars outstanding
we wanted to and originally we thought
that should lapse
um because we had the new funding to
complete the rest of the project but we
found that it would be wise for us to
just go ahead and combine the remaining
eighteen hundred dollars with the
existing uh more recent funding for that
program uh until it is until it's fully
expended so with your permission we'd
like to to retain that
all right so for the committee we're
working on lines 161 through
173 and after line 168 there is from
2019 letter G Communication System
replacement that's what we're discussing
and they would like to add that as a
um
that is in particular was not on the
list originally so we'd like to add that
and then the rest of what was listed
again we'd like to retain
all of the items uh that are that are
listed
um and we're happy to answer any
questions or clarify any concerns that
may exist as a result of of these
requests
oh see none uh was there anything else
you'd want to say I don't think there
would be any problem with
with any of this
um no we have nothing to add at this
time as long as there are no questions
where we appreciate that well thank you
for coming it's always a pleasure to see
since we're off of this uh to go back to
your last present
excuse me last presentation
we talked about excavators
and
you folks had mentioned how difficult it
is to go through the Rental process
and I'm assuming those who are and I'm
guessing but I've talked to a couple
other folks that it's Hoops that are put
in place by administrative Services I
believe to how you have to go about it
or
it's not a matter of calling up and
getting the item delivered it's the
preliminary hoops
it's a matter of procurement process yes
the The Authority that is granted uh for
us to pursue rental equipment agreements
short-term rental equipment agreements
isn't is advantageous for us to have
however the procurement limitations that
are typically still applicable that is
posting bids going to governing Council
following limitations on dollar amounts
and so forth is a very time consuming
process and much of what we do with
rental equipment agreements is typically
in response to very immediate needs in
the field so that really has been the
the big the challenge so my ask to you
is
um
Commissioners should be able to
administer their department and their
budget without a whole lot of
interference any chance you folks could
come up with some language that would
streamline and expedite the process for
emergency situations when you need
something yesterday that we could insert
the language in that'll bypass all these
other Hoops I could certainly talk to
the commissioner and the members of the
respective bureaus and divisions and and
are looking behind you that there might
be some oh
foreign
to your request uh representative Eaton
in the operating in the capital budgets
you can't put statuary statutory changes
in so that would be a house bill 2
amendment that they would potentially
need if they were going to suspend a law
that requires certain
procedures occur in order to obtain uh
the equipment that we're discussing so
they could still come up with the
language you just wouldn't be able to
put it in House Bill 25 it would have to
go into House Bill 2 or some other
legislation and they're done that no
right where to put it and who to get it
done
just need the language very well I will
definitely follow up with the committee
if I look at items 161 here and I
believe you're talking about Community
communication systems replacement and
there was some monies left in there how
many how many
properties
do you do you control with uh
Towers communication and so forth
do you have any idea
we have a approximately 20 communication
sites that this applies to that we're
upgrading the equipment and we break it
down into the North Region and the South
part of the states
roughly evenly split okay if I could
follow up how many how many of those 20
sites are also occupied by Homeland
Security or State Police many of them a
few of them
more than 80 percent of them
I'm not familiar enough to say that well
take home land security out of it
police Communications could you find
that out there four percent with State
Police I'm sorry about 50 percent with
thank you if you could follow up with me
on that I'd appreciate it okay and did
if I could Mr chairman that's why it
didn't come earlier they uh
gentlemen did I see somewhere in here a
lapse on
um expansion of the Mount Washington
septic system
was that one of your items
that was a request request to extend to
extend if if I could get some follow-up
on that project where we are on that
also I'd appreciate it
um if that would be all right with you
Mr chairman
thank you I can give them to you now if
that's true what do you got helpful so
the uh the project is under construction
right now we've got the first Seasons
Construction in this past summer where
we've done the initial site work
including retaining walls slabs on grade
and the treatment plant itself which is
packaged plant is being fabricated at
the company that's doing it as we speak
so by on the cost basis we're about 40
through the project
and we expect the major construction to
go next summer
and it's going to be both the sewage
treatment plant and we have combined
this project with uh water tanks uh
water water system upgrade so both of
those will be going on next summer and
hopefully we'll be uh substantially
complete with that by October but the
treatment plant company needs a full
season of commissioning work so we'll go
into the next season where they'll have
people adjusting the system and making
sure it's actually meeting the standards
that they have to hit for treatment
plants thank you one one last if I could
so when when that is complete and it's
well needed when that's complete will
will it increase the capacity up there
so if
more activity was to happen do you have
some idea of whether it was built for
what we have now or maybe 20 percent
more or something well the system that
we have in place now uh handles about 3
500 gallons per day okay and it was
designed to handle spikes up to five
thousand
so before we started this project we
were getting spikes up to seven thousand
gallons per day regularly
the new system is designed to handle
seven thousand gallons per day with
spikes up to ten thousand thank you sir
at ten thousand we reached the that's
our water supply limit we can't
unless we find somewhere you get water
thank you thank you very much for that
wasn't there some years ago an effort to
uh
combine the radio tower uh forces uh I
think it was under with safety is the
lead agency so everyone wasn't building
their own radio infrastructure and
that's that's what I remember having
happened that's correct we had we did a
study of the summit Communications
facilities to see what would be the the
best way to go forward
we used HL Turner as our consultant uh
they came out uh with a proposal a cost
estimate of about 14 million attached to
it which was way way more than what we
had in mind so we've kind of backed off
to take another look and I it's going to
be considered it's part of the
consideration that's going on now with
the master plan that has just been done
by the Mount Washington Commission and
they're asking for some funds in this
capital budget to do an assessment of
the top of the mountain which will
representative Eaton
it has firstnet done any overlays onto
your Towers any of your towers do you
know I don't know the answer to that
looks like no one else so unless you'd
like to say something else thank you
and we're expecting our next agency at
three so we'll be in a brief recess till
then
that'll be Transportation that's our
while I have everyone here
uh I mentioned earlier that we were
expecting to hear from peas and we did
and they those are items 174 5 and 6 and
they would like all of those uh
continued
but I don't know
yeah I'm just trying to I don't know
questions
the hour being three o'clock we'll call
the committee back and we'll welcome our
last agency the Department of
Transportation so
if you want to whoever wants to come up
please
that's right
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee I'm Andre Briere Deputy
Commissioner and hdot
good afternoon and for the record my
name's David rodrigue assistant
commissioner for D.O.T
we're prepared to go through the uh the
lapse requests line by line if that's
what you'd prefer
um starting on line 184
of
hb25 or we can answer questions it's uh
we're at your disposal
however you'd like to do it is fine if
you want to go line by line however you
want to do it I think that would be good
so we'll start with uh and we're going
to be passing it back and forth based on
our portfolios minus Aviation Rail and
Transit so I'm going to start with that
and then I'll pass it off to assistant
commissioner rodrigue to uh to cover his
and and we'll take it from there as we
go through our various lapse requests
so starting on line 184
State Au 9342 that's the five percent
Federal Aviation match
um and I'll handle uh line 184 I'll
refer back to the same explanation as we
go through because uh for appropriations
of the last biennium
the biennium beginning in 19 The Binding
beginning in 15 the biennium beginning
in 13 as we go through this list it's
going to be the same explanation for the
FAA five percent match and the bottom
line uh the reason we're requesting the
extension is we you know we are spending
older money first if you look at this
particular line line 184 there's zero
percent encumbered right now but that's
because we are spending older money
first this money is still going to be
programmed against requirements and uh
and FAA is going to be matched for fa
projects at our other system airports uh
as time moves forward this this money is
typically spent over about six to eight
years
and as we get into other items you'll
see that uh the reason that we still
have 13 money that we're closing out is
because we try as we spend that old
money
We Lay projects in against it and this
accounting unit can't close until those
projects also close so it's it's very
typically six to eight years that we use
to spend down this money obviously the
coveted pandemic threw a wrench into
some of that and also uh we do
anticipate some additional uh bill money
so moving on to line 185 that's Aviation
management software we're requesting the
lapis lapse extension because that
project is ongoing it's about 10
complete that's our aircraft
registration software and that's on
track for completion as scheduled
line 186 is the public transit bus and
facility match the the real story on
this Labs extension request is that
Rolling Stock has been increasingly uh
difficult to acquire during the pandemic
there's delays those funds are all um
are all programmed
we have the needs based on the age of
the fleet and recapitalization please
sir
days on finance
um when you roll up roll the buses back
in to go to the white Farm
I know for a fact they've been going
offshore and getting top Buck does that
money when they're when they're
auctioned off go back to the general
fund or does it go back to agency
so there there is a combination because
uh uh F uh FTA does require us to roll
that into future your Acquisitions but
at least part of the money does does
roll back depending on how much it's a
split ta yes yes and you don't know the
percentage or I don't off the top of my
head that's something I could definitely
get for you though sir I just know it's
a combination of those two and that's
actually based on a change in policy
from FTA
um just this last year thank you so much
line 187 uh is uh is the accused rail
Improvement the story there is also a
pandemic story
um in that uh contractor supply chain
materials have taken longer than
expected but that is also on track for
completion by the end of this calendar
year
and at that point for after line 188 I'm
going to pass it over to assistant
commissioner rodrigue and I'll take you
through the next few items
great thank you
line 189 is a match for a grant that
that we had submitted
um for the the Main Street Marine
Terminal we were not successful with
that Grant we would like to carry these
forward these funds forward in case we
have successful on a grant in the in the
future
line 190 is a fuel management system
replacement
representative he's eaten that's the
system you asked about last week and
that is in in progress we would like to
continue working on the implementation
of that system we will not spend the
entire 4 million and whatever we don't
spend we will apps
um in the future line 191 is our
Lancaster building repair
um
that project is still in design we're
working with Public Works to get that
out we did have some delays on that
project
line 192 is a
patrol shed and salt shed replacement
project we're in the design
um process for that project yes
representative is that the one that has
the liquid salt or or liquid treatment
or no right this this shed does not we
do make liquid brine out of our Dairy
shed and we share that amongst several
of the other other sheds in the area
line 193 is a work order system phase
two we are implementing a wolf what we
call Wolfie which is work order Fleet
and inventory system and that's a
computer system that lets us plan
schedule and then measure the the work
we do on both dot assets such as roads
and bridges but also on our buildings
and Fleet equipment as well we'd like to
keep working on that line 194 is our
um
biennial salt shed replacement program
that is 1.7 million dollars from the
last biennium we're in the process of
Designing those projects and we'd like
a patrol shed remodel at our Manchester
Patrol shed most of that work is
complete we were able to work out of
that remodeled Patrol shed this past
winter but there's a little bit more
work to do to close up the the books and
close out that account
and I'll pick it up at 196. that is the
fy19 version of the first item I covered
for five percent match for FAA project
the majority of these funds uh in online
196 will be encumbered uh during this
biennium right now you could see it's
about 34 percent spent and we do
forecast the majority of them will be uh
will be spent this biennium
line 197 is the active railroad Bridges
repairs to state-owned Railways and
again this is uh this has been impacted
from Material availability uh during the
pandemic this These funds go to uh to
our much needed Bridge repair on our
active Rail lines so we're requesting
that they be carried forward
line 198 is Coos County rail
improvements again supply chain issues
but the St Lawrence and Atlantic
railroad has ordered and received the
materials and they plan to complete it
during this calendar year
that project so as anticipated it will
be completed an invoice and calendar
year 2023.
line 199 is the public transit bus and
facility matching funds and it's it's
the same story I've been singing on the
transit side that is that is based on
Rolling Stock chassis availability we
are encouraged that it does seem to be
loosening up a bit still not a good news
story but we do anticipate over the next
two years this biennium we should see
okay line 200 Statewide equipment that
was a 10 million dollar project to
replace our
um Fleet equipment all of that money
except for for 85 dollars is currently
encumbered we do want to carry that
forward so we can complete those those
purchases as quite a lag time on
delivery
um line 201 that is the Manchester
Patrol shed I'm Renovations that I
mentioned earlier that project is is
complete and will be ready to to close
that out if I could make a correction
please
um
line 195 is a combination of extra funds
for the Manchester Patrol shed for a
Lancaster building Edition and for the
dixville patrol shed that we asked for
in in 21 and well Manchester is complete
and closing out
um Lancaster and dixville are still
um line 202 can we go back to line 201
so we will honor your request to delete
thank you line 202 that's a Statewide
Life Safety Code improvements that's our
current project that we have that we're
using to address Fire Marshal issues in
uh in our buildings
um making improvements to some boiler
rooms and final design on some crew crew
quarters that we're hoping to
um Implement in the future
line 203 that is our
um 2019 salt shed replacement
um funding group
some of those funds have been expended
on Replacements and designs and we'd
like to carry the remaining funds
forward to continue those Replacements
some of which are under construction and
some of which will be under construction
line 204 is uh Lancaster district office
Edition
um that is currently in construction and
almost complete we'd like to carry those
funds forward so we can complete and
close out the project
line 205 is a 2019 allotment for
Statewide underground fuel tank
Replacements we are in the process of
um completing some projects under that
funding and would like to carry those
funds forward
line number 206 is a document management
software
um there are certain currently several
initiatives from doit that are impacting
this this document software including
our implementation of Microsoft teams in
SharePoint we're letting those impacts
settle out so that we can scope this
properly and we'd like to carry those
funds forward please
line 207 is our initial work order
system appropriation again where we're
completing the design and implementation
of that software and we'd like to carry
those funds forward
line 208 is a 2019 allotment for
um Statewide Fleet equipment we have
um purchase orders out for that
equipment we'd like to carry things over
so we can complete those purchase orders
and line 209 is is the same story is
primarily for vehicle Acquisitions you
could see that uh particular Au is 50
expended
um again this is a pandemic availability
of vehicle chassis and my my comments
previously applied to this item as well
that we're requesting to move forward
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um there's been about three different
line items split up between you
gentlemen uh for vehicle
acquisition that has been purchased and
delayed with all this now as these
vehicle comes over the next several
years would they meet the current
standards or are they going to be
already obsolete by the time they
fulfill the order
thank you for the question
Representative bogert no so the uh the
transit chassis uh
they would not they would not be dated
at all they may you know they might
maintain current standards FDA hasn't
changed those basic standards for quite
some time
um and these Acquisitions are are
generally for new chassis
um and as they're expended it's roughly
the same as my colleague here it's
roughly a decade of use
um give or take that we get out of these
out of these vehicles so they're
replaced on a schedule and that's all
done in coordination with the Federal
Transit Administration but they thank
you for the question it's a good one but
for these particular vehicles they would
and same for the same for the highway
side they'll be current the vehicles we
had ordered have been sold to somebody
else once they came out of the supply
chain
um shortages from covid
line 210 repair arches and and Walpole
this is a a railroad project
um with some Stone arches uh have
um failed and I Bridge maintenance Crews
have have worked with the rail folks to
to go in and Shore those up and clean
those up and we have some more work to
to do on those line 211 is the 2017
underground fuel tank replacement
project
we have some funds that have been
released on projects that have been done
and complete and we'd like to continue
to reinvest those and updating our
underground fuel tank replacement
program
um line 2012 salt sheds again that's a
2017 funding we have some projects that
are ongoing and making use of that
funding and we'd like to to continue
those as well line 213 is a Manchester
Patrol shed that was for the design of
the the patrol shed work that's done
we'd like to keep a little bit of that
going to as Public Works finishes up the
administration of that construction
project we have some charges that will
continue to come in
line 214 is uh dixville Patrol shed
facilities that was
um
the capital appropriation to replace our
Patrol shed in in dixville that's
currently under construction and we'd
like to carry those funds forward to
complete that construction
line 215 is the uh FY 2015 version of
the same FAA match that I've described
earlier that goes to development and
funding improvements of our 13 federally
funded airports
that particular Au is 83 spent right now
we do anticipate by the uh by the end of
this biennium that'll be all spent as
well our general strategy is to spend
all the older funds first and we will
continue to do that
line 216 is a public transit match
um
same story on on pandemic and supply
chain issues there this is the 2015
version of that same line and again we
it's it's a small amount that's
remaining and there's approximately 96
expended and and we do anticipate
um completing that and closing that one
out by the end of this uh this biennium
line 2017 is our 2015 underground fuel
tank replacement project there are still
uh a little bit of funds in there that
are released as uh the projects uh
finished up in the designs are finished
up and we'd want to make use of of those
funds as well
line 2018
is a 2015 Welcome Center project that
provided some Capital funds to do some
work on uh welcome centers
um there's a lot of work there to be
done and we're very careful and and what
we put our funds towards we would
disappointed with a bid we did for the
um little Tim Welcome Center about a
year and a half or two years ago in the
bids were simply too high to to get the
work done at the time
um but we do have more work to to do
there as well
on 219 is again FAA 5 match that's the
2013 version of that very small amount
of money remaining in that accounts
approximately 99 expended
um again as we uh spend down those funds
um we can't close out that Au until
those funds are expended that project is
complete so we do anticipate that
closing out in this biennium
uh lines 220 and 2 I'm sorry go ahead
sir
I was just remarking on how old these
are these are carried forward from
prehistory it really is 2013 and and
again when uh if projects come in under
budget or
I'm sorry sir the next two oh oh yes the
next two 220 221 those are um those are
really the funds that are there so that
we have money available just in case we
need to acquire rights of way and write
a first refusal on rail properties and
uh they're more or less I mean they're
not permanent accounts but they're
considered uh funds that are there only
in the event that we need them for those
purposes and those purposes are
important if we do have those needs it
is important for the Department to have
those funds available
because we have to respond within 90
days to those rights of first refusal
requests so having those funds available
is crucial for our ongoing Mission
that's why those accounts were
established but as you say
representative they are they are fairly
old and they continue to serve their
purpose
same with line 221 that's uh for the
acquisition of railroad and Airport
properties is necessary under the writer
for first refusal and uh because and the
only reason again they exist is because
of that 90-day deadline that we have if
we do need to take action and secure any
Properties or meet our legal
requirements
so with that that does conclude our
lapse extension requests and we're
uh representative bogert
thank you once again
um item 213 was the design of the
Manchester Patrol shed and that was
previous is that also funded in this in
as far as the construction of it yes yes
there's actually three capital items
that that have to do with that
Manchester Patrol shed this first one
was for the design of it there's another
one for the construction of it and then
there's a third one where we came back
to ask for some additional funds once we
get the bids in and current estimates to
complete the Manchester the the dixville
and the Lancaster district office
expansion we keep the design funds
Capital item open because that's what we
use to pay public works for the the the
work they do in the Consultants do their
Architects to design the project and
then oversee the construction as well so
that project's just wrapped up
um punch list items and we'll have some
bills that continue to come in
follow up please
when we're designing these salt sheds is
the basic structure
our the building structure itself if it
was done by itself are pretty standard
as far as the design and then how it
fits on the ground would be the only
deviation in that right for for our salt
sheds the answer to that is is yes with
with a little bit more explanation we
have
um different capacity shed so there
there's there's three or four relatively
standard designs and then it's a site
work as as you say that gets customized
uh so with that being said we as a
department we look at some of the cost
savings hopefully of re utilizing some
of the designs as you move across the
state doing this
representative Edgar uh thank you Mr
chairman and thanks for the answer to
the question
right at the beginning of this on the
189 the four million dollars for the
Market Street uh terminal there Marine
Terminal
um
do you is there any other projects in
the near future you you're thinking of
trying to apply for that's four million
dollars sitting there
um
are we gonna apply for it again or
something similar or
so not that we know of in the immediate
future but as you know and have probably
heard about the iija
um and the federal funding that's that's
available for infrastructure
construction a lot of that money came to
us in Formula funds some of it came to
us and and program funds but there's
there will also be a significant number
of grant opportunities so we do
currently have a Grant application in
right now for the funding of of the
replacement of the general Sullivan
Bridge which is a a pedestrian bridge we
we most likely would not use these funds
to to match at that Grant
um but it's grants like that that we
need to be nimble and and able to apply
for and may need matching funds where we
wouldn't have other opportunities that
we would ask to keep this These funds
for
thanks for follow-up
and also
um
is the work going to be done at the
Marine that it was scheduled for this
this particular Grant was it done some
other way yes that work will be done
some some other way there is a project
that that is completing design right now
um and that work is scheduled to
advertise late this summer
oh
one time thank you
um and is the
is this
okay so there's a design but um how are
you going to pay for it
so we are paying for that with federal
funds with Federal Highway funds that
that work was was done to mitigate the
the impacts from the Sarah Long Bridge
replacement which ties it to
um our Federal Highway funds
one last time please thanks
so yeah I'm familiar with what this
funds was for so are you are you
prepared to do that project you put it
out for design but do you have a funding
mechanism for that at this time we do
that that project is funded at this time
in our 10-year Transportation
Improvement plan okay thank you thanks
how do we repurpose something that's
meant for Market Street Marine Terminal
to a different grant for a different
project do we have a path to do that
through fiscal or something we we do I
think we we come back to this committee
when we have the need and we ask you if
we can repurpose These funds for for
that need and you would give us a yes or
um
sorry I just add one you get you shut
down Dave go ahead I just wanna I'm Bill
Cass the commissioner I also want to add
one one thing I think the language of
that was was written generally enough to
allow it to be used as a a match for
other discretionary opportunities the
one point that that is important is that
we have very little State money in our
in our program we rely on toll credits
and stuff so to compete competitively
for any discretionary grants they
usually look to bring more
they usually look for those
discretionary grants to leverage other
other than federal funds so having some
State funds available to match
discretionary grants makes it um
makes makes it more um a competitive uh
and and
um representative Edgar there are a
number of projects that we are looking
at like I said Dave they've noted the
one we applied for this round because it
kind of fit those those criteria but um
we've talked a lot about Ocean Boulevard
and other ones in in the in the Seacoast
as uh some of the other discretionary
Grant programs focused on resiliency and
climate change come up um we feel some
of those projects will compete
well for those discretionary grants and
and again
being those projects of are all
federally funded uh having some match
having some State match to put towards
those grants and make them more
um
competitive is fairly instrumental so
that's a big part of what that
um
that line item that that uh that Capital
seeing no further questions uh thank you
gentlemen it's always a pleasure to see
the Department of Transportation
now that was our last agency so uh my my
plan would be to
it's right here take tomorrow on the
snow day to write a report for the full
committee and present it to a work